depuis son penalty raté face à la suisse
en quarts de finale de l'euro le sort
semble s'acharner sur quillanais mbappé
arrivé au psg en 2017 alors qu'il n'a
que 18 ans il y en a toujours été
considéré comme le petit prodige du club
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les choses ne sont plus
comme avant entre lui et les dirigeants
du club et même les supporters cet été
qu'il y en avait pourtant émis le
souhait de rejoindre le real de madrid
un transfert qui ne s'est jamais fait
malgré la proposition onéreuse du club
espagnol j'ai demandé à partir parce que
partir du moment où je voulais pas
prolonger je voulais que le club une
indemnité de transfert pour avoir un
remplaçant de qualité avec ses collègues
de terrain le coup ensemble aussi rompu
pourtant le trio mvp neymar messi a de
quoi faire rêver sur le papier alors mba
paix at il un problème de comportement
cet après midi qu'il vienne s'est confié
au micro de jérôme rothen sur ces
vérités l'ambiance du vestiaire et sur
son avenir alors qu'il y en ai ma paix
at il raison de briser la glace
[Applaudissements]
j'aime aussi hissé dans la vie et il a
très très bien réussi sa reconversion ce
qu'il est excellent dans ce qui fait
bravo - jérôme suivra en soirée mais je
te le dis on se connaît depuis longtemps
et je peux te le dire je suis fier de
toi ce faire de ce que tu fais un jeu
soit que tu kiffes ah ouais je prends
énormément de plaisir je le vois un peu
même un peu comme toi c'est ça mais je
suis je suis je prends conseil j'écoute
je vous jure jérôme il a été vachement
lait coûte je pense qu'il a regardé
beaucoup la télé c'est un mec qui les
tient c'est un bosseur et je le sens
ouais c'est vrai que je bosse je pose
comme j'étais sur le terrain c'est ça
ouais c'est pas gagné d'avancé avez du
talent sur le terrain aux siens ouais
mais j'allais bosser plus que certains
c'est ça ouais merci en tout cas d'être
là tu vas tout nous raconter parce que
c'est vrai que cette interview elle
était très très attendu et ya mis rien
palombes à qui est avec nous directrice
déléguée de public vous montez le graet
toutes les semaines
g
ça me fait plaisir ça fait plaisir voilà
je vous le dis voilà dans mais la
prochaine fois kennedy président ou
présidente du groupe j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
alors on va revenir sur cette interview
avec jérôme et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des choses incroyables un cas qui sont
dites déjà comment tu as eu ce joli coup
comme c'est toi qui l'a contacté
histoire qui lui a dit j'ai envie de
parler ouais ouais ça fait ça faisait un
bout de temps déjà j'avais été critique
très critique envers lui sur son
attitude avant l'euro c'est ça c'est ça
et justement il temps n'a pas voulu non
parce que on parle terrain aimerait ça
déborde ça reste autour du terrain et du
vestiaire a démarré le reste m'importe
pas bien j'ai été joueur aussi je sais
ce que c'est drôle se voit alors pas des
critiques comme lui parce que lui est
une star mondiale mais oui après il ya
eu l'euro qui s'est passé comme il s'est
passé avec une déception de l'équipe de
france et de lui aussi il ya eu son
transfert avorté au real madrid le
méritent tous un ouais le début de
saison avec le psg je me suis dit on
d'un moment il ya tellement de gens qui
parlent à sa place il faut il faudrait
qu'ils parlent alors bien sûr je
préfèrerais qu'il me parle à moi et qui
me raconte des choses et on a instauré
cette confiance-là de quillan et surtout
sa maman aussi qu'il ya beaucoup aidé
c'est sa maman qui prend toutes les
décisions peuvent pratiquer le petit le
conseil ouais et puis ils l'écoutent
l'écouter c'est aussi son éducation
c'est pour ça que c'est important qu'il
le fasse pour que les gens sentent sa
lecture elle voulait qu'il aille au real
madrid ou qui reste au psg
mais le fait qu'il veut non mais s'il
veut partir et vu qu'il écoutait
beaucoup sa maman oui c'est que bon ben
je pense qu'elle était aussi d'accord
pour qu'il aille ailleurs donc c'est une
question qu'on t'a raison
alors le psg aujourd'hui c'est c est
vraiment une équipe de stars il y avait
déjà le bape et neymar maintenant il ya
lionel messi qui est arrivé on pouvait
se demander comment ça allait se passer
dans le vestiaire et dans l'interview
qui viennent m backé par juste rentrer
ses relations avec neymar et messi et il
a revient sur une phrase qui a fait
couler énormément d'encre on va voir ça
et tu vas nous en parler quand tu joues
avec messi neymar tu peux être dangereux
partout oui ils te mettre tellement dans
des conditions qui sont quasi optimales
que tu peux être dangereux partout et il
ya beaucoup d' il ya beaucoup de liberté
donc on permute beaucoup aussi donc
c'est pas une position non plus qui est
figé suis pas le numéro 9 9 la
lewandowski qui quittent pas la queue
sous un jour totalement différent qui
prend les espaces qui est capable aussi
de décrocher qui est capable de
m'éloigner sur le côté donc c'est j'ai
quand même une assez grande liberté
mais j'aime beaucoup ça va mais il
aimait qu'on n'est pas sur l'équipe tv
mettez moi le truc unique neymar est un
clochard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
connais je dirais jaune non mais ils
m'ont mis un extrait on était sur rtl
futsal à [ __ ] là mais c'était mon
émission fait
des pressions mais bon là ici c'est vrai
qu'on est là on va pas parler ici numéro
2 s'est exprimé chez toi comment tu es
en raid à khan et jeudi cet extrait très
bon pour tp mais sans révéler où on veut
des clochards on a des trucs comme ça
ben voilà
c'est des choses qui arrivent après bien
sûr que voilà
bien sûr il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
prenne sur nous et j'aurais dû j'aurais
sûrement dû prendre un peu plus sur moi
mais c'est des choses et on en a discuté
sérieusement vincent regrette pas ces
trucs là c'est des trucs à chaud quand
même je regrette pas parce que nous on
est toi tu connais ce monde là comment
ça marche un peu fier mais je peux
comprendre que dehors 10 visible parle
de son pote de secours équipées d'un
clochard ouais qu'est ce qui nous fait
tu vois même contre toi tu as été dans
ce monde là tu sais comment ça
fonctionne je suis d'accord mais je peux
comprendre que ça ait beaucoup de
respect et d'admiration pour le joueur
et l'homme kenema donc à partir de ce
moment là il n'y a aucun patron alors on
va revenir parce que c'est vrai que
voilà il avait dit voilà un moment ce
clochard me fais pas de passer les miens
twitter
arrivez
vous et venez aussi votre franc-parler
sur le verra mais là quand même clochard
oui mais c'est l'expression
notre chroniqueur il ya un petit côté
quand même je te dénigre un peu j'aime
ça c'est pour ça que c'est bien qu'ils
s'expliquent justement mais non c'est
une expression thank you charlie lisant
non et d'ailleurs c'est mon papa lasse
pas bien mais c'est pas c'est pas
méchant je pense à guy giroux non mes
jours actuels ce guignol aussi c'est ça
exactement vrai c'est vrai que ces
inspections malheureusement alors les
gens qui sont pas dans le foot ont du
mal à comprendre aussi et on dit tiens
il dénigre son coéquipier qui puisait
neymar qui est l'un des joueurs majeurs
du paris saint germain mais voilà des
choses dans un vestiaire sur un terrain
il se dit beaucoup de choses même des
insultes par moments entre les joueurs
là il n'a pas insulté mais ça peut
arriver aussi et moi ça m'est arrivé
comme tu comme tu disais sur le sur le
terrain moi ça m'arrivait aussi de de
dépasser les bornes de temps en temps
j'en ai j'en ai dit des bonnes à pauleta
moi à l'époque donc heureusement qu'ils
avaient pas les réseaux sociaux et tout
ça va sinon
gare à ceux qui l'aiment pas moi j'aime
beaucoup voilà il jouait il était
toujours été super sympa ils disent
qu'il a pris la grosse tête qui kills et
qui n'est pas europe et j'ai que messi
lui ça passe pas vraiment bien c'est
vrai ça ou pas écoute là là dessus c'est
difficile pour moi de répondre parce que
c'était vraiment un entretien échanges
très sympas ouais vu qu'il est passionné
de foot il est très respectueux des
anciens dont je fais partie c'est vrai
et donc ça se ressent tout de suite donc
pour moi c'est difficile de dire qui est
la grosse tête non après tu es la femme
et moi ce que je sais c'est qu'on m'a
dit de ce combat n'y est pas il n'y a
pas du tout la grosse tête mais les
potes qui sont avec lui en équipe de
france voilà ce qui arrive c'est
compliqué de parler à sa place des
jamais mais quand à tous qu'il a
aujourd'hui vraiment il a tout il ya il
a c'est un génie il est dans l'un des
meilleurs clubs au monde c'est peut-être
le futur ballon d'or il a un salaire
j'en parle même pas alors comment on va
parler forcément c'est difficile de
garder les pieds sur terre même papilles
en fête millions d'euros 30 millions
d'euros par ans a cessé son salaire
annuel sans tout ce qui est sponsor pub
et cetera donc 30 millions d'euros par
an voilà c'est ça plus avec les sponsors
ont négocié un contrat quatre millions
avec nike enfin vannes qui doit être
autour de 35 millions d'euros par an un
peu plus de 35 et 40 en plus il a des
primes il a des avantages en
en nature donc voilà c'était sans doute
napo 40 millions d'euros net d'impôt
oui incroyable je sais je sais je pense
que le salaire de quillan aujourd'hui il
n'est pas naître d'un mot
c'est les étrangers les étrangers du mal
je partais démarré mais il y aurait eu
des gossip net d'impôt la plains
davantage au psg aujourd'hui je pense
que je pense que d'ici là où il n'y a
pas d'accord aussi nié c'est ça la
banque donc l'année prochaine il est
libre il est libre à partir du 1er
janvier au 1er janvier peut signer dans
n'importe quel club ça c'est drôle c'est
fou alors dans cette interview et vous
avez posées et qu'il y en ait mbappé et
c'est vrai qu'il ya un truc et qui a
fait énormément réagir c'est les cartons
dans la maison parce qu'on voit que
kilian on y vient d'emménager regardez
c'est juste leur photo carton pour m et
m
voilà merci voilà line et cartons
regarder et ça ça fait énormément parler
il nous a reçus chez lui c'est chez lui
oui d'accord et vous a reçu dans sa
maison qu'on veut pas voir du ccc une
dépendance d'accord
c'est pas une cabane un message sur la
wii je vous mets grande détente c'est
une grande c'est une bande dépendance il
vient d'emménager unis rien vous qui
savez tout non non il ay là il est
toujours dense et son appart qui
l'attend nonchalance et un autre très
bien il y en a eu mais un appart
magnifique avec vue sur la tour eiffel
jacuzzi quand terrasses les cartons
c'est peut-être ceux de ses parents
voilà d'accord alors comme il gère son
business assez je sais pas si c'est ce
jeu vous coupent désolé mais je suis pas
si c'est ça parce que j'ai marqué
santiago bernabéu dessus alors j'ai pas
compris moi
c'est comme une version business en fait
il là il a une avocate qui s'appelle
delphine dard hayden qui est hyper hyper
sympa d'ailleurs que j'ai pu rencontrer
quand on a fait notre premier sujet sur
kylie ann hamid a fait pour nous on
monte un peu les bretelles mais qui est
vraiment sympa et c'est elle qui gère
tous ses contrats avec ses parents voilà
c'est vraiment elle qui négocie tout et
qui fait même aussi de la com pour lui
puisque elle contacte quand il ya des
choses qui lui semble fausse dans la
presse qui nous contactent directement
pour nous dire les choses d'accord alors
on vous avait parlé de sa vie privée
dans le dernier public de ses parents
non mais comment il le prend ça parce
que c'est vrai que moi je n'irai pas
voir cyril hanouna ses parents divorcent
bon maintenant je pense que lorsqu'on
plus mais bon voilà non mais c'est vrai
que moi je vois la ccsa peu ça peut être
violent mine de rien de voir en une ses
parents que qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé après je sais pas quel est son
retour j'imagine qu'effectivement il n'a
pas il n'a pas bien pris mais nous pour
nous c'était une information ça fait
vendre là il en a trop de couvin c'était
pas vrai voilà mais oui ça fait vendre
quand on a fait quand on quand on le met
on met des séries lui à la plage l'été
puisque l'été il aime bien cette année
l'état mykonos sur un énorme lyautey
voilà ça ça fonctionne super bien quand
on l'a fait à la sortie de la coupe du
monde forcément ça cartonne c'est le
meilleur numéro de public après sur le
divorce de ses parents nous ça nous
semblait important de le faire parce que
ça pouvait aussi un peu expliqué
certaines
il est très proche de ses parents donc
forcément leur divorce a un impact aussi
peut-être sur ses performances sportives
vous pensez que ça n'a pas tout c'est
sûr c'est usant mais c'est vrai que ça
s'est passé ça peut être aussi en plus
il est très proche de sa mère qui il est
proche de son père ancien oui mais son
père avait été avec le on m'a parlé d'un
rendez vous avec son père au real madrid
sont une vraie ça je sais pas on n'en a
pas parlé de ça on va en parler mais non
mais il voulait y aller de toute l'année
après c'est vrai que c'est difficile de
parler de la vie privée pour rebondir
parce que oui parce que tu sais que
quand ces joueurs là et marien a pas
beaucoup comme ça la presse people
forcément elle est allée à l'affût de
tout sur et qu' il doit souffrir oui
c'est dans ce constat iv joc les chiffes
sûr qu'il ya des maps etc non pas du
tout dit il fait rêver c'est normal
qu'ils gagnent autant mathieu non c'est
pas c'est pas ça me choque c'est pas ce
qui me choque ce qui me choque le beauf
malheureusement ses côtés là commence sa
carrière c'était monsieur parfait ouais
il jouait bien il était gentil joujou
bien des pays donnés à des associations
ils avaient tous et d'allumer un peu et
quand tout d'un coup effectivement
venant public sur un énorme bateau à
mykonos avec 15 filles magnifiques
dessus mais bien sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin de mecs un tout petit peu
vrillé quoi que messi mais d'abord je
dois de profiter mais laissez moi je
voulais vous annoncer la jalousie des
gens à ivry qui s'attend que comme vous
vous dites il a vrillé mais c'est juste
voilà un moment je vous dis les gens
sont jaloux moi je pense qu'il à droite
d'un suivi et qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout
qu'il soit sur un yacht il a volé de
l'argent de personnes il est sur un
yacht avec un slim hanifi et breil
fidélité la fête avec ses potes dans ce
montant
sandra rigot les mecs qui disent ouais
pour l'image mais qu'animal et le mec il
est ce qu'il fait et on sait très bien
qu'ils donnent à des associations s'il
est proche de ses parents je suis pas un
mec qui ont
décalé mais c'est fragile image est
salie la mauvaise image oui la droite
qui fait que après un euro raté alors
arrêté pour les gens pour les gens
s'étaient manila que tu voulais pour
cette
option tu voulais qu'ils partent en
vacances tout seul non mais moi je moi
je n'ai juste pas eu de problèmes mais
ça il va partir seul sur koh lanta c'est
sa fille n'est accroché mais c'est vrai
mais paraît non non mais c'est oui à
satee chaffa nous quand on a traité le
papier on l'a pas du tout fait en mode
comme tu dis et en plus de ça il ya
chaque fois qu'ils nous attaquent tous
qu'il a des forcément des indemnités et
à chaque fois il les reverse à des
associations et c'est l'un des rares à
barboter bien de dire non mais
[Applaudissements]
soleil
c'est aussi une facette et pour lui ça
doit être difficile à gérer c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi que il a voulu
aller voir ailleurs bien sûr voir ce qui
se passait sa frange est à raison et je
pense que ça a joué aussi le fait que
les français voilà à la presse et où je
suis passé pour toi un bien beau la
vessie non mais ça c'est de jouer mais
je veux dire ce sera pareil en espagne
sera pas rien dans mes l'ircem et sauf
que c'est pas là c'est pas sa langue moi
c'est ça donc arretez du mot je m'en fou
peut maintenant je vais pas quoi
alors oui benjamin russe mais c'est
souvent le regard des autres qui change
pas c'est sarah lui il pense que c'est
le même mec qui forcément gagnent
beaucoup d'argent quel est le problème
qui s'inspire heureusement kiss le
plaisir jeu c'est hallucinant et dans ce
pays façon je le dis ça ça mathieu
secret le doigt sur ce qui est vraiment
france est clair que voilà c'est que on
aime les gens on aime les aides les
adultes et ça et à non après il faut les
brûler et qu'ils ont fait défaut ils
sont infidèles à revendre des maîtresses
machin route ou pas d'ailleurs les ons
absolue donnée c'est typiquement
français
son corps et voilà après
ça blesse c'est que la france ressemble
à mathieu il est là le problème
[Rires]
partie joueurs moins tolérants et un
bras surtout dans le milieu du foot
alors moi je n'y connais bien mais je
n'aime pas les trolls et tout ce qui se
passe et les gens on les fait rêver
c'est à dire qu'ils sont comme des
dingues avec certains footballeurs on
les fait rêver y kiffe man et le moins
de retrouver le bon et le moins bon le
moindre match eh ben ça y est ça devient
le joueur détesté il faut s'en
débarrasser et ils se la pètent la forme
est là je suis pas madame est d'accord
mais si je pars d'un grave on a comme ça
mais il ya plein la plupart des gens ils
comprennent le succès des footballeurs
si laurent wolf quand tu vois des
footballeurs avec des bâtiments caixinha
moi je les ai suivis et un moment de
dormir
mais mathieu franchement
et cyril le cmap c'est un des sportifs
les plus généreux c'est vrai à 0,10 par
action dit bon dit il donne énormément
sa fondation y donne énormément avec sa
maman y travaillent elle sait les
à-côtés du foot sur comment aider des
jeunes déjà à son âge il aide des jeunes
il est sa famille il est plein de gens
jérôme eco6 donc franchement dire qu'il
est égoïste qu'il a pété les plombs
c'est là une toute petite facette demba
p voyez plutôt l'homme généreux mais
générosité ou bnc ça roland
chaque échelon matthieu delormeau si
vous aviez le succès de l'année bape et
financier est ce que vous seriez sur un
bateau avec des fils était oui bah oui
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais
là bas parce que
bernard tapie disait notre faute c'est
un foot de jean mesquin et jaloux je
trouve que tu es jaloux
j'ai bien fait sourire et qu'elle y as
raison c'est un acharnement après l'euro
les gens sifflent et à la furia la map
et ça a été super dur pour lui nous on a
besoin de champions avec du un peu avec
du panache qui ont des rêves décembre
aucune quantité d'air après on a des
petits mecs là qui la joue petit
bourgeois l'été je vais te verrais bien
mais les choix des mecs lice mais bien
sûr le problème dans le foot et c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu des exemples de stars
bien sûr les joueurs qui a été je vais
pas citer sur l'iss mais jamais rien
que l'on excepté des gens quand tu
gagnes craignent en euros par an par
heure par mois par mois voilà ils
attendent effectivement rien
mais cette idée rap ou que tu joue moins
bien forcément s'en prennent à toi à 4
millions d'euros adjugés ça me paraît
pas aberrant là ça a été super dur pour
lui donc a pas de problème